[Musique]
beaucoup mais je ne sert plus les mâles
des gastros là partout cette fois
observer maquettage une race là je me
dis est ce que cette personne à la
gastro non mais sans rigoler mois
maintenant le solide qui va me serrer la
main
ils amènent ces analyses avaient joui à
gap
vous avez encore cédric tenter un
copier-coller stylistique non mais ce
qui est fou c'est que je sais pas quand
on veut s'habiller à chaque fois ma vie
comme vous non mais c'est ça fait deux
fois d'affilée oui c'est la seule chose
que j'espère ne jamais prendre de vous
c'est vos cheveux merci moi c'est
l'argent c'est quoi que je dise à
l'argent il faut pas le prendre chez
vous ça vous avez bien l'argent ne
m'intéresse pas où ça va c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça si l'argentin est la plus
souvent ont la cote chez les ja khamsa
qui avec d'aujourd'hui vous avez vu
c'est l'animateur marocain c'est une
énorme star au magazine les réseaux
sociaux et hamza à l'évolution qu'il
pourra quand on la sait pas si ce matin
bien boire au bureau m dit ouais siritsa
magique est super ce soir madiba
chocolat je pars demain bat julie battu
v autour de la table tu fermes ta gueule
[Rires]
ça va très très bien je suis très
content des caméras comme il est
sympathique mais surtout commodités
tribu piolot l'eau voila voila c'est
vrai c'est à dire il est mignon et ça va
dit qu'on a envie de le manger ça aurait
mené 0-1 manie coty à mon frérot alors
que très content c'est un truc aime bien
je t'aime
merci
j'attends un bon show alors vas-y toi
alors oui comme ça des trucs sur anna
non pas du tout à coup sûr vous plutôt
comme tous les jeudis j'ai regardé
balances ton poste l'émission n'aurait
pas où cyril hanouna porte même costard
que pascal promet qu'à la même façon de
parler que booba s'achève bientôt lieu
arlette chabot parler comme ça ce qui
est bien avec vous c'est que comme tous
les plus grands journalistes politiques
vous avez toujours des propos modérés
franchement c'est impressionnant tabata
le financement et la iv riddla l'évêque
l'année alors qu'il fait l'annoncé lors
des travaux de juger on ne sait pas quoi
leur émission de merde l'homophobie
comme très timide et pas contre l'islam
ont porté ces mots que toi qui l'a fait
qui m'interpelle oui mais c'est moi qui
ai encore là les mecs là on est dans un
truc là où son ca nous avons s'emballer
car avec vos fonds d'âge de politiciens
on en a rien à [ __ ] arrêté on ressort
les choses arrêté avait rien chiffres
nous on voit on donne notre ressenti
c'est le ressenti d'agathe mois les
chiffres je vous le dis qu'ils sont
collectées pour moi c'était de la merde
pour l'heure il n'y a pas fait de
meilleurs chiffres peuvent [ __ ] au cul
aussi un coup de chiffres alors si tu me
faisais le footeux cul voilà
on dit les choses mal a rappelé laurent
ça y est elle est très très bien je
l'aimais beaucoup
en europe tous motards vous obligez pas
préféré d'emballant son poste aux dents
touche pas à mon poste
voilà je vous le dis il ya un côté que
je préfère à l'autre autant dans btp
dont vous savez aujourd'hui pour le côté
je préfère c'est ici ouais enfin pas
merci ici ça cela c'est la moyenne d'âge
années de 202 en votre look oeuvre quoi
faire la moyenne d'âge d'affaires
[Rires]
moi si je passe il dit pas soucier si je
ne reçois zen magistrats du csm
[Rires]
62 c'est avec tout le monde l'appelle
[ __ ] dans les soirées mondaines et
youtube alors ce qu'on aime dans
balances ton post c'est que même si ça
finit à 4 heures du matin on peut pas
s'endormir
parce que sa gueule tellement comme
voisin crawl c'est moi qui m'en brouille
avec ma mère et j'ai remarqué quelque
chose de marrant avec vous si elle
n'avait jamais remarqué quand vous
essayez de suivre un peu les débats
musclés ou fait un truc très marrant
regarder alors comme d'habitude on va
dans ton post l'ambiance est posée et on
comprend absolument tout ce qui se dit
à la cei comme vous suivez les débats
deux balances ton post on dirait que
vous êtes dans les tribunes de roland
garros j'avais jamais vu ne nous
empêcherait le jeu de mots qu'il a fait
raquette d'arrivée je néglige pas s'il
va le voir c'est magique magic ici on le
revoit en plus un laser sur assiette
garrido parce qu'elle s'appellera
qu'elle raquel raquette n'y a qu'un pas
tennis tracts c'est fou on a ajouté la
toute fin pourvu basket pagny baptisé
merci beaucoup je fais pas la main ou de
tout autre chose ça qui est bien est ce
que tu as alors la table ronde des
séries on a beaucoup de points communs
on aime les films de bagarres on est fan
des photos de sa main le club comme
celle ci par exemple n'est pas du tout
vrai l'épaule cette fois c'est
magnifique on sait c'est très fort voit
jamais posé comme ça excusez moi non
plus mais il ya un truc qui nous sépare
c'est que vous changer de coiffure aussi
souvent que benjamin castaldi change de
femme
oui mais quand même et donc je dis vous
avez animé deux émissions une soirée
vous avez créé un nouveau concept
l'animateur qui change de coiffure entre
ces deux émissions regardées c'est
magnifique à 18h46 vous lancez touche
pas à mon poste avec une coiffure qu'on
qualifiera de classiques et vous quand
vous vous ennuyez avant d'enchaîner une
deuxième émission vous faites quoi vous
allez chez le coiffeur
[Applaudissements]
là vous allez gagner moi non regard des
autres conducteurs 46 1 heure 35
ça me parait que c'est pas fini je vois
c'est pareil alors justement comme ou
changer de coiffure toutes les 10
minutes alors que michel drucker il a la
même coiffure depuis 1957
je me suis dit la prochaine étape pour
vous c'est quoi je pense que la
prochaine étape c'est que vous allez
changer de coiffure plusieurs fois en
pleine émission serait comme les meufs
non dans les consciences et les tenues
vous cette pandémie sion alors j'ai
voulu imaginer ce que ça allait donner
avec des effets spéciaux de notions
incroyable tu sois déçu on sont utiles
quand même et y en a eu d'autres
s'agacent l'iniquité le belge louis côté
il ya eu aussi une équipe c'est kim
formidable à la meilleure imitation de
gérald en souvenez vous c'est patrick
timsit
bah ouais voilà regarder celle de timsit
mais c'est de la merde oui l'effort
il est fort il est fait divise ce pays
si je fous cinq ou six steven spielberg
alors série depuis quelques temps méfiez
vous parce que je sens monter la révolte
des chroniqueurs ici ils font des coups
de pression
il se permet vraiment de vous venez de
plus en plus alors les ouvriers se
révoltent contre le patronat y en a qui
peuvent faire une croix sur
l'augmentation des patrouilles à part de
ce qu'il m'a pas moi en tout cas
regardez c'est le ba-ba clash
[Musique]
entre 14000 et 33000 euros entre 14000
et 33000 euros
et combien gagnent silvana par minute
une émission oui je dis un truc temps là
rien à taper quoi oui c'est vrai vous
aimez le danger dans la vie amoureuse ou
b line on annonça la vienne on voulait
acheter de l'eau de l'eau n'importe quoi
et on a démonté aventure david et la
voiture sur un parking à l'entrée de
limoges pour trouver une pièce à moi ça
veut dire arriver ça aussi au pea je
peux pas avoir d'argent payée même à les
avait démontés trouvera pas du tout
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez une idée était à me
dire peut-être avant tout à l'heure il
n'y aurait été content vous concernant
oui tard
capricieux exercice boudeur on a des
joueurs autoritaire mauvais déplacement
sur le terrain
égocentrique cette émission de qualité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà qu'elle est encore un petit peu
souffrante voilà et ça n'est pas la
gastro l'a priori d'après ce qu'on sait
voilà on a quelques infos médicale voilà
ce n'est pas une gastro on va voir d'où
ça vient et d'où provient de mal on va
alors vous reparler mon amie isabelle
morini bosc qui a un grand regret dans
sa carrière elle aurait rêvé de faire du
one woman show acer si elle s'habille en
rouge c'est pour faire comme anne
roumanoff on sait bien le problème c'est
que le rouge c'est seul point commun
entre toutes les deux parce que niveau
et nous on a la preuve que tous les
soirs franchement elle est plus proche
de michel leeb que de gad elmaleh voici
leur tolérance brolin michel labbé drôle
hein ah bon ah oui excuse moi mais très
bien voici le redis la belle et drôle
mais vous allez voir que oui justement
c'est le retour de grand mère c'est
faire un bon café mais pas des bonnes
vannes mais pas des bonnes bonnes et
donc est ce cas là ces lignes aux
basques à l'appel pour perdre du poids
[Rires]
avec le faux journal il osé tout et
c'est pour ça qu'on les mêmes vous
souvenez ah oui vous savez attend pas et
à l'oreille ah bon parce que j'ai mis
mon stylo à la hausse y aller on a fait
un tour directement sur france 3
on va terminer c'est dans cette image
[Applaudissements]
sympathique c'est ça c'est vrai que j'ai
dit non pas garde ils ont fourré et ben
moi il ya dix ans il ya une dame qui
voyant qui m'a chopé la même dans la rue
mais qui me dit que genre total trois
enfants donc moi je vis seule solution
c'est aller à lourdes maintenant parce
que pour les trois enfants c'est raté
en fait elle remarquer après il faut les
revoir à la première fois ça marche pas
la deuxième phase a commencé à lécher
rial tabac qui arrive dans la 30e
édition du ternois barrès je vais gagner
pour la 20e fois le tard baba réponse
dans un instant les shérifs à l'état
d'abandon série baba c'est quoi pour la
20e fois alors le fameux pas c'est quoi
c'est celui ou celle qui a le plus
tacler ses collègues toute la semaine et
ça fait dix neuf fois d'affilée que vous
gagnez oui c'est vrai à chaque fois vous
gagnez vraiment de ça donc je pense ou
gagné une vingtième fois forcément ce
serait particulier pour vous réitérer la
musique de suspense cette semaine encore
eu beaucoup de vent beaucoup de punch
lines au plateau et cette fois là non ça
va être beaucoup plus solennel
cyril je vous assure regarder en face de
vous justement
le 26 août à rabat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa faute on joue comme ça alors vous
avez été encore très très très très fort
cette semaine c'était franchement cette
semaine y avait pas de discussions je
traînais allons regarder pourquoi le
fruit de votre travail souvient
téléspectateurs merci à vous chers ça
c'est leur faire comme important merci
vous savez c'est vraiment un ennemi son
ami ce grotte de lascaux c'est pas des
paupières qui l'afer lui mon père vient
déjà vu la d12 porte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour lui la règle est sur une chaise
arbitres on vous avait déjà sauvé
quelqu'un vous vous voulez sauver
quelqu'un barrez vous dénichent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui va calmer les esprits qui
va dire quelque chose dont on se fout
certainement fabien vous tous qui est
mouillé et la mauvaise haleine ah ouais
alors ça c'est relou vous n'êtes pas si
elles sont cousins c'est sa soeur
jumeaux mais je m'en bats les couilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]